en sortant du jim sonia constate qu'à
côté de sa voiture et défoncé et que le
mystérieux coupable a disparu malchance
son auto n'est pas assurés contre les
collisions doit protéger en cas de délit
de fuite
heureusement tout n'est pas perdu comme
l'incident est survenu au québec
elle pourrait être indemnisé par la
société de l'assurance automobile
jusqu'à concurrence de 10 mille dollars
elle doit notamment rapporté l'incident
la police pour plus tard dans deux jours
et faire sa demande d'indemnisation
d'ici deux mois
mais sonia devra être patiente elle
devra conserver son véhicule tel quel
tant que la saaq de la bavure et elle
devra payer elle même estimation
sachez aussi que les dommages doivent
d'être supérieur à 500 dollars pour
avoir droit à une indemnisation
la société dispose ensuite de 60 jours
pour donner sa réponse
et comme avec une compagnie d'assurance
sonia devra payer une franchise d'au
moins 500 dollars le fin mot de
l'histoire
vous n'êtes pas assurés contre les
collisions parc avec délit de fuite vous
avez une protection mais armez vous de
patience